so far we have offended the good people
of hot ofena and Gore well that's all
right I don't see them very often I wish
them well wh your point is turns out
Wayne Brown doesn't know where Gore is
so let's meet up with Cameron from huoi
hge and go and plan a tour for him good
day Cameron good day B how's it going
good out yeah not too bad mate you ready
to plan this trip for Wayne Brown oh of
course I am awesome let's go jump on the
logging
truck uh where's all logs mate uh we
don't do that much for strle oh yeah
probably know that let's go here is
where Wayne Brown is in Oakland then he
would fly down the country pass horino
all the way down to gore at the bottom
of the South Island he can swim though
well if he's any relation to a brown TR
yeah you want some brown
Speedos oh
definitely way brown stripy ones are
ring you his into his
art yeah I can definitely that man
yeah there quite a few openers M there
we especially after Wayne got
eled take him down to e South Gill good
check out some ofage building yeah we
can uh do we can write wank can
s oh he' be a brilliant T yeah we get
down for the Country Music Festival
though definitely ar ar can even make a
great y
then we can go go get some Mo afterwards
oh yeah of course go out take Wayne
Brown out brown fishing and is brown
Speedos and then go for a brown beer I
like the I like it a lot of people are
just a bit more children right yeah not
so highly struck exactly but it still
feels like you're in a city at the same
time Ral City L it us same parking
phones in Gore I don't imagine it's a
great problem to park in Gore you
probably Park a logging TR G for
all I know about G camera mate I I don't
think you can park here well it's too
busy down here oh yeah true oh well way
Browns
[Music]
okay